سلام به شما حالتون خوب باشه بالاخره شروع
کردیم ضبط ویدیوها من یه ذره بدغل شدم ریه
درگیر شد زلزله اومد ۱۰۰۰ تا شاب سنگ و
اینا اومد ولی خدا را شکر داره همه چی ضبت
میشه الان تصویر دارم لایو می‌گیرم همه
چیو اوکی کردم همه چیو به هم وصل کردم که
دیگه با کمترین سختی بتونیم بیشترین بازی
رو داشته باشیم این ویدیوها مناسب چه
کسانیه وقتو تلف نکنیم سریع بریم سر اصل
مطلب ببینید بچه‌ها ویدیوهایی که داره
آماده میشه اگه بخوام مصداق بگیرم دوره
جامعه معامله‌گری رو می‌گیرم مثلاً مثلاً
عرب وغلقه‌ها خب س قسمت عرب وغلقه‌ها
داشتیم یعنی یک و د و سه که میشه همون وی
۵۴ ویدیو اصلی گزارش‌های هفتگی و بعدشم
ویدیوهای تکمیلی یعنی یک و د و سه اون یه
داستانی بود که جمع شد و تو ۹۰ قسمت یعنی
صفر تا ۱۰ کارو می‌تونید با اون دربیارید
حالا بچه‌هایی که اون ۹۰ قسمتو دیدن با
دیدن این ویدیوها مثل یه نیترو می‌مونه
براشون مثل سریال ارباب حلقه‌هاست الان
این که قراره انجام بشه و واقعاً مصداق
خوبیه به نظرم حالا هایلایت‌های پیچم اونا
حکم به پشت صحنه کارو داره یعنی استراتژی
رو اونجا گفتم دیتیل گفتم ریز ریز ولی
پخشه چون حس می‌کنم با اینکه توی
هایلایتها من اکثر این استراتژیها رو گفتم
ولی خب چون نوشتم تکست نوشتم خیلیا دقت
نمی‌کنن حتی دقت کنن شاید متوجه اون
نکته‌ای نشده باشن خیلی واضح‌تر میخوام
نکاتو اینجا بیان بکنم قول داده بودم که
تو ۱۲ ویدیو جمعش بکنم ولی امیدوارم که
جمع بشه چون فکر می‌کنم جمع نشد تو ۱۲
ویدیو یعنی بهذر هر ماه میخواستم یه ویدیو
بدم ولی نشد متأسفانه اولین ماه ولی الان
با قدرت ادامه میدیم بریم سر مطلب کارمون
خیلی از بچه‌ها اصلاً وقتی حرف استراتژی
می‌زنیم یه غول چراغ جادو میاد تو ذهنشون
که اصلاً خیلی پرت از داستانی که واقعاً
داره انجام میشه. یعنی حرفای این ویدیوها
رو اونایی بیشتر درک می‌کنن که قشنگ تو کف
ماجران و می‌دونن چه خبره. بچه‌های
آوتورترم قشنگ می‌تونن ازش دیتا بگیرن
دیگه. یعنی دارید گل کارو می‌بینید. یعنی
شما سال‌ها برو بچرخ این‌ور اونور به به
در و دیوار بزن خودت تو مارکت تهش می‌رسی.
یعنی برمی‌گردی پیش خودمون. خب مطمئن باش
که این ته کاره. یعنی بعد از این دیگه
سیاهیه هیچی نیست دیگه بالاتر از سیاهی هم
رنگی نیست امیدوارم که مطلبو درست گفته
باشم من کلاً تو گفتن مثل کلاً خیلی
داغونم بریم سر اصل مطب کارمون من برم روی
چارت با هم بریم چار من تصویروم کلاً الان
قطع می‌کنم از اینجا میریم یعنی روی چارت
من تصویر خودم نباشه که حواستون پرد نشه
کلاً تمرکزمون بره روی چارت خب قبل این که
بریم رو چارت قراره در مورد یه سری
موضوعات خیلی مهم صحبت بکنیم با همدیگه
موضوعاتی که به ظاهر ساده است ولی دقیقاً
چیزیه که بین تریدر آموتور با تریدر
حرفه‌ای تفاوت ایجاد می‌کنه یعنی این اگه
این بلد نباشی کاملاً آوتوری و چه بسا
بچه‌های حرفه‌ای‌تر که فکر می‌کنن حرفه‌ای
شدن ولی ر اینا رو رعایت نمی‌کنن و ایراد
کارشون دقیقاً از همین جایان میشه. چه
مثلاً خیلی از بچه‌های حرفه‌ای‌تر که الان
منتظر من سریع نمودارو باز کنم، سقف و
کفهای پ بالاتر بکشم، استراتژیا رو روی
اینا پیاده بکنم و بگم این این در صورتی
که بچه‌ها استراتژی خیلی فراتر از
این‌هاست یعنی صرفاً این هم هست ببینید
این هم اصلی‌ترین قسمت استراتژیه. شما
مادامی که این چیزایی که قراره در ادامه
بهتون بگم رو ندونید و اجراشون نکنید همه
حرفای من به کلاً بریزید دور بره به کار
نمیاد. مادامی که اصلاً مشکل از اون جایی
شروع شد که شما نرم‌افزار متاتریدر رو باز
کردی توی گوشیت و یا رفتی تو تریدینگ ویو
اومدی یه چارت دیدی گفتی ا تریدینگ ویو
چقدر جالبه چارته داره کندلا بالا پایین
میشن ا اینجا خریدم اومد پایین فروختم سود
کردم اصلاً مشکل ما از هم اونجایی شروع شد
که مستقیماً رفتیم رو چارت یعنی همون اول
کار رفتیم رو چارت همه بچه‌ها که شروع
کردن یعنی خود منم وقتی شروع کردم اینجوری
بود دیگه من اومدم یه اولین چیزی که از
بازار شنیدم رفتم یه سری نمودارو باز کردم
دیدم اه چقدر جالبه و این باعث شد که
مدت‌ها دور خودمون بچرخیم. پس بیایید با
هم این قضیه رو کلاً منتفی کنیم و بریم
خیلی دقیق یه بار از صفر مطلق از یک مطلق
شروع کنیم با همدیگه کار کردن. بچه‌ها
استراتژی یعنی اینکه ما بدونیم دقیقاً چرا
می‌خوایم وارد بشیم. اصلاً دلیل این
ورودمون به این بازی چیه؟ چه زمانی باید
وارد بشیم مثلاً چه تایمی از روز معامله
کنیم؟ چه تایم فریمی معامله بکنیم و کجا
قراره خارج بشیم؟ این خیلی مهمه که کجا
قراره خارج بشیم. یعنی همونقدر که ورودی
ما به معامله مهمه که چه کجا ورود بکنیم
اینکه کجا خارج بشیم و چرا خارج بشیم هم
مهمه که سبک‌های مختلفی داره که همه رو با
هم کار می‌کنیم یا وقتی که مثلاً بازار
خلاف جهت من رفت مثلاً می‌خوام خارج خارج
بشم از این معامله و عکس‌العملم چیه اصلاً
اون موقع یعنی اگه وارد معامله شدم یا
اصلاً می‌خواستم وارد معامله بشم و یه
انتظار داشتم این بره بالا نرفت بالا و
یهو اومد برعکس اومد پایین این عکسالعمل
من توی این نقطه چیه؟ اینا همه توی یک
پکیجی هست به اسم استراتژی و خیلی بیشتر
از این‌ها همه این‌ها تو اینه یعنی
استراتژی فقط این نیستش که اگر یه کندل
اینجا شکسته شد به سمت بالا ما اینجاشو
کرز کنیم رو کرزش بخریم استپمونو بذاریم
اینجا و به همین اندازهش بریم بالا این هم
جزئی از استراتژیه استراتژیه و اینا همه
تو پکیج اینن و به طور کلی استراتژی یعنی
اینکه یه برنامه‌ای داشته باشیم که قبل از
اینکه بازی بخواد شروع بشه بدونیم که
قراره چیکار کنیم نه اینکه وسط معرکه‌ای
که قراره مارکت شروع به کار بکنه بعد که
شروع کار کرد ما بریم الان تازه باید
چیکار بکنیم بخرم بفروشم یا تصمیمات
لحظه‌ای بگیرم یا احساسی بگیرم اینجا دیگه
من تریدر نیستم اگه بخوام به این سبک کنم
ما قمارباز میشیم اونطوری اگه بخوایم بر
اساس احساس کار بکنیم همونجوری که م کجا
شما تو زندگیتون تصمیماتتونو بر اساس
احساساتتون مگه می‌گیرید مثلاً یه ق یه
لحظه میگم خب الان برم خونه بخرم میرم
خونه می‌خرم نه پشتش کلی فکره بعد میرم با
یک پلنی اون اون کارو انجام میدم ترید هم
خارج از چیز زندگی نیست پس چرا باید
تصمیماتمونو به این شکل بگیریم وقتی
می‌تونیم به سبک منطقی‌تر با تومنینه
بگیریم توی مرحله بعدی چیزی که باید ما در
نظر داشته باشیم اینه که سیستم و استراتژی
د تا چیز متفاوتن یعنی اینکه ما با سیستم
کاریمون با سیستمی که می‌خوایم پیاده
بکنیم ممکنه یه سری فیلتر باشه مثلاً بگیم
آقا یه فیلتر می‌ذارم رو مارکت اگر به این
عدد رسید به اون عدد رسید ما می‌خوایم این
فلان کارو بکنیم این میشه سیستم معاملاتی
من اما استراتژی اون طرح عملیاتیست اون
چیزی که من تکرارپذیره باید کامل باشه و
قابلیت ارزیابی داشته باشه یه زمانی هست
سیستم قابلیت ارزیابی نداره فقط میگیم که
یه سری اتفاقاتی امکان وقوع دارن اما من
اینا رو نمی‌تونم بک تست بگیرم اما وقتی
در حرف از استراتژی می‌زنیم این استراتژی
باید قابلیت بک تست گ‌گیری داشته باشه و
این بک تست گ‌گیری اساس کار ما توی
سیستم‌های معاملاتی به طور کلی استراتژی
یعنی کهه یه مثلاً ما یک سچوشن داریم یا
مثلاً ما یه موقعیتی داریم یه موقعیت
که مثلاً جفتشونم موقعیتشون مثلاً اینه
این شکلیه د تا موقعیت عین همدیگه و هیچ
تفاوتی با همدیگه نمی‌کنن اما من باید
بدونم که آیا اینا رو تشخیص بدم مثلاً بگم
این موقعیت دقیقاً شبیه به همین موقعیته و
من قراره توی این د تا موقعیت مشابه
عکسالعمل مشابه داشته باشم به همدیگه یعنی
نه وقتی که این اینجا اومدم مثلاً زدم پس
کله یه نفر اینجا اینجاهم قراره بزنم پس
کله یه نفر قرار نیست اینجا زدم پس کله یه
نفر اینجا واسه یه نفر جفا بگیرم خب یعنی
عکسالعمل من بعد از دیدن یک اتفاق برابر
باشه همون کاری که بعداً قراره بکنم و
دوباره اگر این اتفاقو دیدم دوباره همون
کارو بکنم اگر دوباره اینو دیدم نرم بزنم
جفا بگیرمش دوباره بزنم پس کلهش این قصد
قضیه تکرارپذیری ماست و همین طور علاوه بر
اینکه ما قراره عکس‌العملمون نسبت به یه
موضوع یکی باشه یعنی اگر یک رو دیدیم
بدونیم بعدش د رو قراره ببینیم دقیقاً
باید فردا هم دنبال یک بگردیم یعنی همون
جوری که امروز مثلاً داریم دنبال یه الگوی
سراشوره می‌گردیم مثلاً بخواد یه امتیای
تشکیل بده من اینجا وارد معامله بشم این
امروز اگر دنبال این قضیه گشتیم و اینجا
وارد شدیم و استپمونو گذاشتیم اینجا فردا
هم دقیقاً دنبال دنبال همچین شکلی بگریم
با یه ذری شاید تفاوت داشته باشه مثلاً
این دفعه بیاد از پایین‌ترش بزنه اما
کانتکست کلی همون شکل باشه و من بدونم که
این دقیقاً یه اتفاق ق مشابه که داره
میفته و فردا هم قراره من همین واکنش د رو
نسبت بهش داشته باشم یعنی مثلاً روی این
نقطه سلم رو بگیرم استاپم اینجا و دیگه
تفاوت نکنه این دفعه دیگه اگر اومدم این
بالا سل گرفتم دیگه کار د رو نکردم عملاً
یه کار شماره سه کردم یعنی این کار شماره
سه منه که این کار شماره ۲ و شماره ۳
کاملاً متفاوتن از همدیگه و من نمی‌تونم
اینا رو اگر بخوام یکی بگیرم بندازمشون تو
یه ترازو بگم آقا د و س۳ یکی کی بود؟ حالا
ببینم نتیجه من بعد از ۱۰۰ تا معامله چه
شکلی شده؟ نه این شکلی نیست ما اگر دو رو
دیدیم یا اومدیم اینجا سل گرفتیم فرداهم
اینجا سل گرفتیم می‌تونیم بگیم آقا من یه
کار مشابه کردم فردا اگر اومدم اینجا این
کارو کردم نباید بیام بگم دوباره این الگو
رو انجام دادم و این الگو رو دیدم که
مشابه این الگو بود پس د تا چیزی که
متفاوت انجام میدیم نتایجشونو با هم برابر
نباید بذاریم و در نهایت استراتژی یعنی
رفتار ثابت ما در برابر نتایج متغیر بازار
این یعنی اینکه اگر امروز ما یک حرکت ایک
انجام دادیم و نتیجه شد
وادا اگر ایک انجام شد و نتیجه شد ز ما
بدونیم که اگر ۱۰۰ بار ایک رو انجام بدیم
ممکنه نتیجه وا ز وا حالا بریم جلوتر
این‌ور مثلاً ادامهشو بنویسیم ایک دوباره
ز همین جور ادامه ادامه‌دار باشه و ما
نمی‌تونیم این رو پیش‌بینی کنیم پس ما
باید رفتارمون همیشه این فلشه باشه ما
همیشه یه رفتار ثابت باید داشته باشیم ما
ایکو دیدیم
می‌زنیم پس کلهش ایکسو دیدیم می‌زنیم پس
کلهش ایکسو دیدیم می‌زنیم پس کلهش حالا
ممکنه زدیم پس کلهش یه بار راشو کشید رفت
یه جا اومد اونم زد در گوش ما دوباره راشو
کشید رفت سود کردیم سود کردیم راشو کشید
رفت یه بار اون برگشت زد در گوش ما یعنی
باید بپذیریم که زدن پس کله طرف برای من
احتمالاً د تا نتیجه خواهد داشت یکی که
ممکنه بره راشو بکشه بره به نفع من باشه
یا اونم برگرد یه دونه بزنه زیر گوش من پس
این د تا نتیجه رو باید بپذیریم اول و
رفتار ما ثابت باشه این رفتار دار ثابته
وجود داشته باشه در مقابلش بریم سر مطلب
بعدی که به نظر من اگر این مطالب رو شما
خیلی خوب درکش بکنید روانشناسی معاملاتی
اصلاً نیاز ندارید روانشناسی معاملاتی کسی
میره آخر سر گیرش میفته که اصلاً اینا رو
در درک نکرده باشه و اگر اینا درک کنید
اصلاً دیگه روانشناسی نیاز ندارید شما
دیگه ساختار مارکتو فهمیدید پس نیازی به
روانشناسی معاملاتی دیگه ندارید این یعنی
چی این توضیح ریسک و گین در استراتژی بازی
اعداد نه احساس یعنی که آقا خیلیا فکر
می‌کنن کلاً استراتژی خوب این استراتژی که
پشت سر هم سود کنیم ما در حالی که یه
استراتژی خوب یعنی توزیع درست ریسکمون در
برابر گینی که می‌گیریم یعنی توزیع ریسک
در برابر گینی که می‌گیریم حالا این یعنی
چی؟ میبین فرض کنید که یه استراتژی داریم
که فقط تو ۳۰ مواقع سود می‌کنه. این یعنی
اینکه توی هر ۱۰ تا معامله ۳ بارش مثلاً
سود میشه ۷ بارش ضرر میشه ولی هر باری که
این ۳ باره سود می‌کنه ۳۰۰ ۳۰۰ دلار مثلاً
سود می‌کنه تو هر باری که ضرر می‌کنه ۱۰۰
دلار ضرر می‌کنه اوکی ۱۰۰ دلار ضرر بذاریم
اینجوری ضربدر بذاریم حالا اتفاقی که تو
۱۰ تا ترید میفته ۳ تا ۹ تا سود کرده ۷ تا
یکی ضرر کرده ۷ تا و این در مجموع سودده
بوده ۲ تا ریوارد گرفته من اینو به عنوان
یه مثال دارم براتون میگم می‌خوام فقط
اینو ببینید که این یعنی بازی اعداد نه
بازی احساسات نه اینکه من حالا نبندم
چاررو بگیرم حالا نه اینو ببندم د تا منفی
هم شد عب نداره اینه که آقا شما یه عددو
بالا پایین می‌کنی توی سیستمت کلاً داری
این فرموله رو خراب می‌کنی پس کلاً این
احساسه رو باید بذاری کنار هر چیزی که
سیستمت داره میگه هر عددی که باید بسته
بشه هر عددی که باید بسته بشه چه به سودت
چه به ضررت باید این کارو انجام بدی چون
این بازی اعداده نه بازی احساسات حالا
می‌خوایم اینو بازترش بکنیم و ببینیم از
نظر روانشناسی داستان چیه این روان من اگر
بیاد هفت بار سود بکنه چه اتفاقی سرش
میفته یعنی اون نکته طلایی این سیستم اینه
که اگر توی اون هفت بار ضرر ممکنه که ۷ت
بار ضرر متوالی بشه یکی ۲ تا ۳ تا ۴ تا ۵
تا ۶ تا ۷ تا و این توالی ضررها رو هیچکس
نمی‌تونه پیش‌بینی بکنه و بعدش بیای ۳ تا
سود بزنی و وقتی که توی ۳ سه تا باخت اول
شما روحیتو از دست بدی چار تا باخت اول
روحیت از دست بدی و استراتژی رو دیگه کار
نکنی یعنی از اینجا به بعد بگی برم یه کار
دیگه بکنم برم مثلاً یه حرکت دیگه بزنم که
این چارتها رو جبران
کنم اینا رو جبران کنم بعد حالا دوباره
میام دوباره به استرژیم برمی‌گردم هیچوقت
قر اون موقع به این سود بزرگه نمی‌رسی
یعنی این ۱۰۰ دلاریا رو ضرر کردی ۱۰۰ تا
۱۰۰ تا ۱۰۰ تا یه ۳ تا ۳۰۰ تا در انتظارت
بوده که تو هیچوقت اینو نمی‌گیری چون همون
اول کاری ازش جا زدی دیو و رفتی کنار و
دقیقاً تو همین نقطهست که ما می‌رسیم به
مطلب مهم بعدی روانشناسی توضیح سود و ضرر
این یعنی اینکه فرض کنید این صفحه‌ای که
من دارم آینده معاملاتی منه یعنی این صفحه
سفید که دارید می‌بینید جلوتون آینده‌ایه
که من هنوز تشکیلش ندادم هر دایره‌ای که
من دارم می‌کشم هر دایره نشون‌دهنده یه
پوزیشن سوددهه یعنی توی ۱۰۰ تا معامله
قراره من با ریوارد یک حتی یکا بچه‌ها
ریوارد د منظورم نیست الان داریم میگیم
ریواردمون ریسک به ریواردمون یکه و اگر
نمی‌دونید ریسک به ریوارد چیه این ویدیو
اصلاً مناسب شما نیست من بازم تأکید
می‌کنم که این ویدیو سطحش یه مقدار بالاتر
از سطح مبتدیه و این مثلاً این مطلبا رو
می‌تونید با چت جی بیتی صحبت بکنید دیگه
یعنی مثلاً بپرسید آقا ریسک پریوارد چیه؟
مطالب سختی نیست که بخوایم در موردش
بخوایم وقتتونو بگیریم اما من بازم
گوشه‌هایی اشاره می‌کنم در مورد مانی
منجمنت صحبت داریم نه ری صرفاً ریسک به
ریوارد من اینا رو براتون کشیدم که ببینید
این توضیح ما بوده و این
ضبدرها ضررهای منه من قطع کنم اینا رو
بکشم این صفحه که الان داریم میبینیم توش
پر از معاملات سوددهه که این دایره‌هاست و
پر از معاملات ضرردهه و من هیچوقت
نمی‌تونم توالی اینا رو تشخیص بدم حالا
فرض کنید که ما نمی‌دونیم توالی به چه
شکله. وقتی توالی به این شکل میاد سلکت
می‌کنه خودشو از مارکت ما نمی‌دونیم مثل
یه گویی می‌مونه مثل یه ظرفی می‌مونه که
ما نمی‌دونیم اگه دست کنیم توش قراره چند
تا ضربدر برداریم پشت سر هم یا نه قراره
چند تا پشت سر هم دایره برداریم. اینجاست
که ما باید یک مفهومی رو با هم کار کنیم.
مفهوم ندانم‌گرایی.
ندانم‌گرایی یعنی اینکه در هر نقطه‌ای از
مارکت از شما پرسیدن که آینده این مارکت
چی میشه؟ یعنی مثلاً ۱ ساعت بعد چه خبری
قراره بشه؟ جواب شما باید یک چیز باشه.
نمی‌دانم. اطلاعی ندارم. خب جواب معروف
باید باشه. چون ما نمی‌دونیم آینده چه
چیزی قراره رخ بده. ما نمی‌دونیم با این
معامله‌ای که من ضرر کردم آیا بعدی هم
ضرره؟ آیا بعدی هم ضرره یا بعدی سوده؟ و
وقتی اینو بدونم دیگه مغزم آروم می‌گیره.
دیگه دنبال این نیستم که بدونم چی می‌خواد
بشه. دیگه دنبال این نیستم که هی بشینم
پای چارت بالا و پایین رفتنشو هی اینجوری
نگاه کنم میام معاملهمو ست می‌کنم و میرم
فورگتش می‌کنم ست ان فورگت معاملمو
می‌کارم چ حالا چه به صورت لیمیت یا به
صورت اردر مثلاً
استاپ و کارمو انجام میدم برای تئوری به
نظر من تا اینجا کافیه همین که ما درک
کنیم یک صفحه‌ای وجود داره که ما
نمی‌دونیم توالی سود و ضرراش به این شکل
خواهد بود سود قراره به من بده یا نه به
این شکل ۲ تا سود یه ضرر بخواد به من بده
اینو درک کنیم اصلاً روانشناسی معامله‌گری
نمی‌خوایم روانشناسی معامله‌گری این
استرس‌ها طمعها از جایی میاد که ما هی
می‌خوایم بگیم من می‌دونم من بلدم من
می‌دونم بعدی سود میشه میرم حجممو می‌برم
بالا یا نه می‌دونم بعدی ضرر میشه اصلاً
دیگه معامله نمی‌کنم این‌ها این
پیشگویی‌ها مثلاً باعث میشه که شما تریدر
نشی هیچوقت چون یه تریدر در اولین چیز
میگه آقا نمی‌دونم اطلاعی ندارم هیچی چی
نمی‌دونه فقط ما اکشن می‌بینیم و ریاکشن
میدیم از مارکت که در ادامه حالا باز
می‌کنم براتون برای تئوری فکر می‌کنم کافی
باشه بریم دیگه مطالب روی چارتو با هم کار
کنیم کند در مورد کندل‌ها صحبت بکنیم دیگه
با همدیگه خب بریم با روز خونین طلا شروع
کنیم امروز ۱۲ می هستیم روز خونین طلائه
دوشنبه صبح بارکت باز شده و همین توی چند
دقیقه گذشته طلا از
۳۲۷ تا
۳۲۲۰ اومد اومد یعنی تقریباً ۵۷ دلار ریخت
توی همین چند دقیقه یعنی از ساعت ۱۰ تا ۱۰
و چند دقیقه دیگه میشه ۱۰ و۳۰ دقیقه ۱۰ و
۲۸ دقیقهست تو ۲۸ دقیقه ما ۵۰ دلار ریزش
طلا رو تجربه کردیم حالا اینو واسه چی
گفتم واسه اینکه اگر تایم فریمو ببرم
مثلاً روی ا۴ شما تو ا۴ هم دارید این عدد
رو می‌بینید ببینید این کندل رو به عنوان
یک تارگت می‌بینید یعنی شما اگه مثلاً
تایم فریم مثلاً ۴ ساعته هم کار می‌کردید
تارگت زده زده بودید اگر تایم فریم مثلاً
اچ وم کار کرده بودید تارگت زده بودید حتی
دیلی هم فکر می‌کنم ببینید منطقاً اینه که
کسی که اینجا سل گرفته باشه با اپن این
مارکت برای اینکه استاپشو گذاشته باشه
بالای این سطح تارگتشو زده چون اگر بخوایم
ریسک به ریواردم در نظر بگیریم برای یه
کسی که دیلی مثلاً میخواسته اینجوری
تارگتهای اسکلپی بگیره الان رو تارگت دوشه
خب بچه‌ها قبل اینکه من برم رو اسلاید
گفتم اینجا یه دونه پوزیشن براتون بگیرم
اینو من برای این می‌گیرم که بعداً
توضیحشو بدم خب داستان اون که خودتم بعداً
میف فهمیه من اینجا می‌خوام یه پوزیشن سل
بگیرم آخر ویدیو متوجه میشید که چرا گرفتم
دودهم و استپم رو می‌ذارم
بالای این سط حالا اگر بیاد به این سط
برسه به این بالا برسه یعنی بیاد حدود ۱۶۰
دلار ضرر منو بزنه من میام یک عکسالعمل
دیگه‌ای تو این سطح بهش میدم ریسک
پریواردشم بذارم البته اجازه نداد خشک بشه
فعلاً شدید رفت تو سود این حسابهم همون
حساب است بچه‌ها که با هم کار می‌کردیم
اگه یادتون باشه من تو سفر آلمانم کجا
دقیقاً آلمان بودیم فکر کنم آره که ۱۰۰۰
تا شارژ کردم ۵۰ ۰۰۰ تا سود کردیم توی اون
سفر بعدش اون ۱۰۰۰ تا رو دوباره برداشت
کردم این سود اون ۵۰ ۰۰۰ تاست که من دارم
رو همون الان ادامه همون حسابه دیگه
بچه‌ها به طور کلی اولین چیزی که تو دنیای
ترید ازتون می‌خوام که انجام بدید اینه که
همه چیز رو اینجوری یه موج نبینید که این
شکلی داره میره و و شما اینجوری به موج
بری باهاش جلو
جلو بگه این موج و اینو یه موج بگیری و
صرفاً با همینا بری جلو. می‌خوام ازتون
دقیق‌تر باشید. دقیق‌تر چه شکلی می‌تونه
باشه؟ اگر پراکس اکشن زبان چارت باشه این
کندل‌ها کلمات اونن. ببینید این کندل‌هایی
که داره تشکیل میشه هر کدومشون دارن یک
دیالوگی رو به ما میگن که باید تک به تک
خوانده بشن. حتی اگر تو تایم فریم یک
دقیقه‌ای باشیم مثل چیزی که الان هستیم.
چرا که عکس اصلاً همونجوری که تو چند
دقیقه قبل دیدید ما تایم فریم‌های پایین
ام۱ ام
فا ام۱ اینا رو کار می‌کنیم و نمیریم تایم
فریم‌های بالا بهخاطر اینکه تایم فریم‌های
بالا اصلاً موضوع تریدشون فرق داره. اون
چیزی که تکنیکال خیلی قشنگ و تمیز روش
جواب میده تایم فریم‌های پایین هستن. اما
تایم فریم پایین به این معنی نیست که شما
باید از این کندلا فرا بذاری کنار دیدن
کندل‌ها رو چرا که ببینید این چند کندل
پشت سر هم دارن به ما واضحاً میگن مارکت
بیجونه و انتظار اتفاق بزرگی نداشته باش
فعلاً مادامی که اومدی چند تا کندل پشت سر
هم دیدی که داره یه قدرتی توو به تو یه
قدرتیو به تو میگه و مثلاً این سه تا کندل
که اینجا تشکیل شده با این س۳ تا کندل و
این س۳ تا کندل دارن چیکار می‌کنن؟ می آقا
ما توی یه رنجیم ما جون نداریم داریم
اینجا در جا می‌زنیم این کندل‌ها که دارن
به ما راغو نشون میدن و ازتون می‌خوام تک
به تک کندل کندل به کندل یعنی چی؟ یعنی
اینکه این کندل که اینجا تشکیل میشه شما
باید کندل بعدی رو که می‌بینی ببینی که
این یه هایی داشته یه مثلاً یه کلوزی
داشته یه اپنی داشته و یه لوی داشته این
سه تا کندل بوده کندل بعدی هم یک لو داره
یه اپن داره یه کلوز داره یه های داره
این‌ها رو باید به ترتیب ببینی ببینی که
این های بالاتر از این هایئه ببینی که این
کلوز بالاتر از این هاییه اگر بخوای
همینجوری چشمی اینجوری به چارت نگاه کنی ی
نمی‌فهمی داره چه اتفاقی میفته باید کلمه
به کلمه این چارتو قورد بدی و اگر تایم
فریم ۱ دقیقه که فکر می‌کنم برای خیلیا
زوده تایم فریم‌ها رو ببرید بالاتر ۵ و ۱۵
دقیقه‌ای هر ۵ دقیقه بیا ببین این کلمه چی
گفت به ما چی داره میگه آیا اومده کلوزش
پایین‌تر از چیز زده یه کلوزی زده که
پایین‌تر از سطح قبلیه یعنی به رکعت به من
تحویل داده یا مثلاً اومده از اینجا تا
اینجا د تا گپو تو دل کندلا داریم با قدرت
داره می‌ریزه یا نه؟ مثل مثلاً کجا بگم؟
اینجا
یه اتفاق خیلی کوچولویی داره میفته یا
مثلاً مثل
اینجا داره کندلای من اکستند میشن. واسه
همینه که ازتون خواهش می‌کنم اول کاری
دارم بهتون میگم باید به این شکل به مارکت
نگاه کنید. حالا بعد از اینکه اینو دیدید
میاید این ترن لاینا رو می‌کشید. این ترین
لاین دیگه اینجا داری می‌بینی که آقا قبل
از این بریک اوته این شکلی نیومده بخوره
بهش. یه قدرتی داشته یک یه سقف ۲ سقف ۳
سقف ۴ ۵ ۶ تا سقف پایین‌تر زده و این ۶ تا
سقف پایین‌تر دارن من داد می‌زنن که من
می‌تونم روی سل این نقطه حساب بکنم.
بچه‌ها الان دوباره همون اتفاق داره
میفته. من دوباره اینجا یه سل دیگه
می‌گیرم چون این دقیقاً همون رفتاره دیگه.
ببینید یک سقف پایین‌تره سقف پایین‌تر سقف
پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر برگشته به همون
محدوده. من سل می‌گیرم باهاش. تارگتم
کجاست؟ تارگتم آر یک اینجاست. یعنی از
اینجا به اینجا واسه من بریزه. یعنی آر ۱
من تقریباً برابری می‌کنه با همون آر
قبلیم. حد ضررمو می‌ذارم این
پشت. و ببینید بچه‌ها من الان پوزیشن قبلی
که گرفتم استاپش اینجاست. اون استاپش
اینجاست. حالا من اگر این حسابو بیارم
بذارم اون بالا میشه زیربیری ردش کرد از
نظر من ولی عملاً دارید انگولک می‌کنید
نتیجه معامله دومتون رو به خاطر اینکه
معامله اولتون یه جایی تارگت داده پس شما
حتماً باید این کارو بکنید در صورتی که
استاپ این معامله اینجا بوده استاپ این
معامله هم اینجاست و ما اینا رو با هم
باید تفکیک شده در نظر بگیریم نه اینکه
مثل همدیگه در نظر بگیریم و بچه‌ها این
داره یه اصلاح کوچیک به سمت بالا میده یه
لگ وان داره می‌سازه یه لگ تو می‌سازه من
حس می‌کنم از اینجاها دیگه یه ریزش سمت
پایین داشته باشیم. فکر می‌کنم نمی‌دانم
اطلاعی ندارم اما اینجا من چون دو ایکس
وارد میشم یعنی وارد سل میشم من توی همین
محدوده‌ها شروع می‌کنم یه سل دیگه زدم. خب
اون مقداری که می‌خواستم و رفت. علامت
سلمم زدم استاپمم می‌ذارم همین جا یه
اسپردم لحاظ بکنیم براش. ۳ تا معامله فعال
داریم بچه‌ها. این به این معنیه که این
معامله دوم من که یک سناریوی جدایی داشت
الان میانگینش میفته این وسط. یعنی یه
معامله اون بالا داره، یه معامله این
پایین میانگین این د تا میفته این وسط و
عملاً وقتی برسه پایین‌تر دیگه من ریوارد
یکو نمی‌گیرم. اینجا عملاً دارم ریوارد ی
و نیم می‌گیرم اگه بریزه. ببینید تو این
مواقع هست که دقیقاً اون تفاوت تریدر
حرفه‌ایه با تریدر آموتور مشخص میشه دیگه.
شما اینجا باید بپذیری آقا ما نمی‌دونیم
نتیجه چیه ولی پای معامله می‌بینیم اینجا
نمیام تق تق تق اینا رو ببندم. ما اینا رو
از قبل گرفتیم. بکتی تستش می‌دونیم آقا در
یک احتمال وقوعی این میره استاپ می‌زنه.
در یک احتمال وقوعی قراره بره تیپی بزنه
اما من نمی‌دونم این اون دفعه‌ایه که
قراره تیپی بخورم یا این اون دفعه‌ایه که
قراره استاپ بخورم. پس به همین واسطه
تلاشمو می‌کنم، کارمو دارم انجام میدم و
انگولک نمی‌کنم چیزای دیگه‌ای رو. حالا
معامله اولمم به ایک دو ایکس داره نزدیک
میشه. اگر برسه به اینجاها به این محدوده
چیز من بکشم براتون. اگر یه ذره دیگه
میومد بالا من معامله دوممم می‌زدم توی
این من محدوده.
خب بچه‌ها من حجممم کردم چهار ددهم چون
دیگه فاصله تا استاپ کمه میام چیکار
می‌کنم؟ با حجم بیشتری وارد
میشم. خب بالاخره آمدیم روی اسلایدها و
می‌خوایم آموزش استراتژی اس پی توو با هم
کار بکنیم. بچه‌ها اولیه کار بهتون بگم.
اس پی تو یه نامگذاریه که حالا من انجام
دادم روش به استفاده از اسپاک تول و خب
چیزی بوده که من باهاش کار می‌کنم. مدتا
دارم کار می‌کنم. ترکیبی از چیزایی که یاد
گرفتمه و بچه‌ها ببینید اول کارو بهتون
بگم لطفاً گول اسامی رو نخورید تو کلاً تو
فضای معامله‌گری در سراسر دنیا یعنی در
سراسر دنیا میای مثلاً می‌بینی یه سیستم
معاملاتی اومده دبل اچ مثلاً تی نمی‌دونم
مثلاً یا دبلی اچ سازمان بهاش جهانی اومده
یه سیستم معاملاتی داده بیرون این معمولاً
برای بازاریابیه میان چیکار می‌کنن مثلاً
میگن آقا اینو مثلاً ۴۰۰۰ دلار به من بده
من سیستم معاملاتیو به تو یاد بدم بعد
میری می‌بینی ا همون مطالب مطالب مثلاً
اربروکسه که همون مطالب مثلاً وایکوفه که
مثلاً اینا که همه رو بلد بودم که خب خودم
اینا رو می‌تونستم ترکیب بکنم بعد میایم
چیکار کنیم میایم میگی آقا اینجوری شده
بعد میگه خب به من چ میخواستی نی سر کلاس
این تقصیر ماست که باعث میشیم که این
اتفاقا بیفته اسمگذاری صرفاً برای اینکه
اینو من یونیک کنم اینو تو ذهنتون باشه
اسپی تول برای این کهه من اینو یونیک کنم
استراتژی بعدی که میخوام بهتون یاد بدم
قاطی اونا نشه گفتم بعداً اسپی تول بدونید
که منظورم کدوم استراتژیه این بحث
نام‌گذاری فقط گفتم یه پیشزمینی بهش بگم و
اما خود استراتژی حالا چرا من اومدم ۲ تا
مفهومی که قوی هستن رو با هم ترکیب کردم
بهخاطر اینکه این استراتژی رو می‌خوام
برای عموم انجام بدم یعنی عموم مردم بیان
با این استراتژی می‌تونن کار بکنن و
سختشون نباشه یعنی چی سختشون نباشه به طور
کلی من یه توضیح در مورد اسپاک اول بدم
برای بچه‌هایی که نمی‌دونن اسپاک یعنی یک
حرکت قوی در مارکت اگر مفهوم اسپایک و
اینا رو نمی‌دونید یعنی هنوز از پرایس
اکشن زیاد سر درن نمیارید و باید برید
مطالبشو بخونید چه از می‌تونید از دوره من
استفاده کنید چه از مطالب آقای اربروکس و
کتاباش استفاده بکنید هر کدوم که خودتون
راحت‌تر هستید اما من بازم یه توضیحی
بهتون میدم در مورد خود اسپاک ببینید
اسپاک یعنی یک حرکت شارپی که بعد از یک
حرکت رنج انجام شده حالا این رنج معنی یک
رنج بلند نیست وقتی که مثلاً چند کندل این
شکلی داریم پشت سر هم
می‌بینیم حالا مثلاً نه اینقدرم همشون این
شکلیا ممکنه توش یه دونه فولبادی هم باشه
ولی دوباره همون فولبادی برگشته اومده
اینجوری شده بعد دوباره یه دونه اینجوری
شده بعد دوباره یه دونه اینجوری شده
دوباره دوباره یه فولبادی داریم. این یعنی
که آقا من نمی‌دونم به خودم چندم. همونجور
که بهتون گفتم شما باید به عنوان یک تریدر
سقف و اپن و کلوز و کندل لوشو براتون مهم
باشه. مادامی که چارت رو این شکلی نبینید
یعنی نبینید که یه سقفی بالاتر از این سقف
زدیم یه کف پایین‌تر از این سقف زدیم
اصلاً به درد نمی‌خوره. یعنی اصلاً زبان
چارتو متوجه نشدید و اصلاً اینه که میگیم
زبان چارتو یاد بگیر. زبان چارت یعنی چی؟
این استعاره هست چی؟ یعنی همین دیگه این
کلمات چارتن مثلاً یه دونه نزولی اومده
زده اینگلف کرده کندل قبلیشو و اومده کل
کندلو پوشونده اومده اینجا یه کلوز
پایین‌تر داده این یعنی کهه من زبانشو
بلدم فهمیدم این کلوز رفت پایین‌تر از این
لو فهمیدم که این لو پایین‌تر از این لوئه
فهمیدم که این های بالاتر از این های زده
شده این‌ها مطالبین که باعث میشه شما کمکم
چشمتون عادت کنه کلمه به کلمه چارتو نگاه
کنید حالا این حرکت پرقدرت به چند روش
ممکنه انجام بشه
روش اول اینه که بیاد کف‌های بالاتر بزنه.
ببینید یه کف بالاتر این لوئه اینجا لو
بعدی لو بعدی لو بعدی ما اینو توی همه
این‌ها داریم
می‌بینیم که اومدن لوهای بالاتر زدن و
واقعاً ازتون تقاضا دارم چارت رو این شکلی
ببینید خواهش می‌کنم چارتو این شکلی
ببینید ببینید ممکنه بعد از این دوباره
همین طور بره
بالا و این چارت همین طور بره بالا و این
هی لوحهای بالاتر بزنه و تو روندای صعودی
شما هی چشمتون به این لوحه باشه هی ببینید
دارید چهجوری میشه تو س روندهای نزولی
چشمتون به این سقفه باشه ببینید سقفه داره
فرض کنید این الان چارت برعکسه فکر کنید
سقفه داره میاد پایین سقفه رو ببینید داره
چه اتفاقی براش میفته این سقفه براتون
خیلی باید مهم باشه چرا کهه در ادامه
می‌فهمیم که نقطه ورود اصلی تریدرهای اصلی
مارکت این نقاط هستن اما یه فرقی دارن این
و این و این و این درسته همشون یک حرکت
پرقدرت بودن اول مارکت اونم اینه که بدنه
و شدوهاشون ممکنه با هم هم‌پوشانی داشته
باشن این تأثیر می‌ذاره تو قدرتشون. نه
اینکه صرفاً قدرتشونو کم کنه، فقط تفاوت
ایجاد می‌کنه. حالا تفاوت کجاست؟ اونجایی
که من دارم استراتژی یاد
میدم و این استراتژی ممکنه چندین بخش
باشه. یعنی هر کدوم از این شاخه‌هایی که
من دارم می‌کشم یه استراتژی که من قراره
بهتون یاد بدم. مثلاً تو استراتژی زمانی
اینجا قراره کار کنیم. استراتژی اسپاک
محور اینجا. استراتژی تریدین ریج محور
اینجا استراتژی کانال محور اینجا و اینا
هر کدوم فرق دارن دیگه. این تایمیه این
اسپایکیه این تریدینگ رنجیه این کانالیه و
هر کدوم یه داستانی دارن و خود این
اسپایکه بچه‌ها خودش مثلاً چند شاخه میشه
مثلاً دو شاخهش همینجا مشخصه دو شاخهش یکی
این حالته و یکی این حالته حالا این دو تا
حالت چه تفاوتی با همدیگه دارن حالت اول
شدوهای بلندتری داره و این شدوهای بلندتر
باعث شده که ما بین شدوها هم‌پوشانی داشته
باشیم. می‌بینید کندل قبلی با کندل بعدی
هم‌پوشانی دارن. می‌بینید اینا هم‌پوشانی
این کندلاست و این هم‌پوشانی باعث میشه که
ما این ترند یعنی در دل خودش یک سری
اصلاح‌ها داشته. یعنی من اگه برم دل این
ترند و ببینم این چه اتفاقی براش افتاده
توی کندل اول ببینید مارکت باز شده اومده
پایین بعد رفته بالا بعد اومده پایین تو
کندل بعدی یعنی این کندل دوم مارکت اومده
یه مقدار رفته پایین بعد رفته بالا بعد
اومده پایین اینجا کلوز کرده تو کندل بعدی
مارکت باز شده و اومده دوباره این پایین و
دوباره رفته بالا و دوباره اومده اینجا
کلوز کرده مثلاً می‌بینید بچه‌ها این ک
موج کندل اوله این موج کندل دوم دومه این
موج کندل سومه و کندل بعدی هم دوباره
اومده یه دونه اومده تو دل اینجا و رفته
بالا و اومده اینجا کلوز کرده ببینید در
واقع اینو می‌خوام بهتون بگم که وقتی میری
تو دل این ببینید چقدر خوشگل داره برات
کانال ساخته یعنی عملاً این یه کانال بوده
که من اینو باید برم تو سبک کانال محور
تریدش بکنم اسپاک کجا انجام میشه جاهایی
که یک بریک اوت اتفاق افتاده یه بریک اوت
ولید ببینید اینجا یک بریک اوته این یک
بریک اوت یک بریک اوت بریک اوت زمانی
اتفاق میفته که کندل ما میاد یه کلوزی
می‌زنه و کندل بعدی هم نمی‌تونه یعنی اون
کندل فالورو یا همون کندل دنبال کننده یا
همون کیبار که بعد ازیز میاد این سیگنال
بارمونه اون کیبارمونه نمی‌تونه بیاد به
این محدوده برگرده این کندل دوم بالاتر
بسته میشه و نمی‌تونه با این یکی
هم‌پوشانی داشته باشه این اگر میومد پایین
هم‌پوشانه ایجاد می‌کرد عملاً برای من
دوباره یه مفهوم کانالو ایجاد کرده بود
اما من نمی‌خوام با کانال کار بکنم اینجا
می‌خوام دنبال دنبال اسپاک بگردم. پس
دیدید بچه‌ها تفاوت این د تا چیزایی که به
ظاهر خیلی شبیه هم بودن چقدر زیاد می‌تونه
باشه و چقدر شیرینه وقتی که می‌فهمیش که
چرا داره این اتفاق میفته. پس این یه کندل
بریک اوته. یه نشونه خیلی ساده هم داره
توش پی گپ داریم پی گپ گپ فشار داریم پرژر
گپ و این متفاوت از ای گپ. خب اگر حالا
بازم مفهوم ای گپ و پی گپو نمی‌دونید باید
ویدیوی مخصوص گپ‌ها رو ببینید که هم تو
دوره هست هم می‌تونید از منابع مختلف گپو
پیگیری بکنید اما مفهوم پی گپ و ای گپ و
کامان گپ که گپ مشترکه و گپ صبحگاهی و
اینا اینا رو من تو ویدیوها گفتم و کاملاً
چار تا چیز متفاوت از همن هر جایی که ما
گپ می‌بینیم نباید بگیم این گپه صرفاً این
گپه این گپها ذاتاً با هم متفاوتن لوکیشن
تشکیل‌گیریشون خیلی با هم تفاوت ایجاد
می‌کنه اما دقت داشته باشید بچه‌ها این‌ها
هنوز چیزنا
بریک اوت محسوب میشه ببین کلوز بالاتر از
سقف قبلی چیو بریک اوت کرده سقف کندل قبلی
رو بریک اوت کردیم این هم ترنده ببینید
مفاهیمی رو فکر نکنید این ترند نیستا این
هم ترنده اینم ترنده فقط نوع ترندش تو
همون بحث استراتژی با هم تفاوت دارن و
نوعی که ما باید اکشن و ریاکشن بدیم روشون
متفاوتن همونجور که تو معاملات دیدید که
الان انجام دادم براتون یک سری کندل ایجاد
شد و به همین شکل ترند به سمت پایین زد که
ترند قوی داشت ش من با اولین پولبک اومدم
چیز کردم وارد معامله سل شدم و اینو
همینجور امتداد دادم چرا؟ چون من دارم
مفهوم ذهنیم اینه که وقتی همچین ترندی
داره شکل می‌گیره توی اینجا یک سری بایر
وارد مارکت شدن که مارکتو کشیدن بالا حالا
این بایرها دیگه نمی‌خوان قیمت به اینجا
برگرده به این سطح پایینی برگرده چون اگر
برگرده عملاً هر آنچه که زحمت کشیده بودن
و ترند داشته از بین رفته و عملاً دیگه
این ترند ترند ولیدی نیست پس ما می‌تونیم
روی این حساب کنیم که توی این محدوده از
همین بالا تا این پایین بشه محدوده خرید
ما من دوباره اینو جلوتر توضیح میدم اما
بیایم با یه جمع‌بندی بکنیم که این رو
فعلاً حذف می‌کنیم از معاملاتمون حالا
بریم تفاوت این سه تا رو با هم بررسی کنیم
اتفاقی توی این ۳ تا ترند افتاده از نظر
مفهومی یه چیزه اما از نظر تعداد فرق داره
بحث اولی اینه که آقا ما هر سه کندل رو یه
ترند در نظر می‌گیریم و الزاماً نباید ۴
کندل باشه خب وقتی که میاد یه دونه از یک
سطحی که این سطح ماست یک بریک اوت اتفاق
میفته و یک سیگنال بعدی که میشه کیبارمون
کیبار این بالا بسته میشه یا فالورومون
اینجا بسته
میشه فالومون اینجا بسته میشه این به معنی
اینکه ما یک ترندی داشتیم که قدرتمند بوده
و آمده کار ما رو انجام داده اما چیزی که
برای نشونه‌گذاری می‌تونیم ازش استفاده
بکنیم این پیگپ هست که ما رو خیلی راحت
می‌تونیم با چشممونو دیگه تشخیص بدیم که
تفاوت یک بریک اوتی که اتفاق افتاده کجاست
توی کندل اول ببینید وقتی که این سقف با
این کف هم‌پوشایی ندارن یه گپی اتفاق
افتاده که یک بریک اوت از اینجا اتفاق
افتاده با یک فالات تو رو اف تی دوباره
اینجا ببینید ما اینجا نداشتیم این گپه رو
اما تو کندل بعدی اتفاق افتاده و دقت کنید
نکته اصلی این چار کندلی که گذاشتم
اینجاست توی حالت اول ما یه بریک اوت
داشتیم بعد ادامه داد سقف‌های بالاتر زد
یعنی بخشید کف‌های بالاتر زد ال ال زد تو
حالت بعدی اول کف‌های بالاتری دیدیم و بعد
اومد گپ تشکیل داد. از نظر مفهوم و ذا این
د
تا یکی هستند و ما توی این استراتژی د تا
رو یکی در نظر می‌گیریم. می‌تونید این‌ها
رو هم از هم تفکیک کنید. دوباره بیاید
اینو دو شاخشهش بکنید بگید من اگر اومد
اولش گپ زد بعد با این یه استراتژی
متفاوتی ایجادش بکنم که واقعاً هم میشه و
احتمالاً من در آینده این د تا روم ازم
تفکیک کنم. اما چون ذاتن خیلی شبیه به همن
و دیگه خیلی پروفشناله. های پروفشناله که
من بخوام اینا رو از هم توی این ویدیوها
جدا بکنم میام میگم آقا این د تا رو
می‌تونیم ازهم تفکیک بکنیم ولی الان
نمی‌خوایم این کارو انجام بدیم پس چه در
حالت اول که اومده یک س بریک اوت انجام
داده و یه فالا تو رو بعدش داده و ایجاد
گپ پرژر گپ کرده یا بعد از این اومده یه
اول لوهای بالاتر زده بعد ک گپ ایجاد کرده
یا به محض اینکه لو رو ایجاد کرده و تموم
شده دیگه کندل بعدی اینجا نزولیه ببخشید
اینجا از اینجا شروع میشه نزولی اومده
پایین این دیگه نه نرفته بالاتر احتمالاً
واسه همینه ۳ تا کندل گذاشتمش این کندل
بعدی اومده پایین این س۳ تا حالت‌هایین که
ما داریم در نظر می‌گیریم همونجوری که
الان توی ویدیو دیدید من یک سلسله مراتبی
از حرکت‌ها رو دیدم که همه اینا رو با به
مسابع اسپایک گذاشتم حالا همونجوری که از
اسمش پیداست ما داریم میگیم اسپایک تول
حالا مفهوم تول یا همون ای بی مساوی سی دی
اینو می‌تونید توی اینترنتم سرچ بکنید
مطالب براتون زیاد میاره می‌تونید اینو
استفاده بکنید ازش اما چیزی که وجود داره
اینه که تو اینترنت شما اینو خیلی کلاسیک
می‌بینید مثلاً میگه A و بی رو بگیر تا سی
برو مثلاً یه فیبوناچی می‌ندازه میگه از
اینجا بخر بفروش اما اینجا داریم در سطح
کندل در سطح کلمات اومدیم پایین و اینجا
داریم با هم کار می‌کنیم پس وقتی در سطح
کلمات اومدیم پایین و داریم پروفشنال کار
می‌کنیم و احتمالاً هر کندل من ۱ دقیقهست
ام و یا تهش ام یا ام فا ام میگم پس دیگه
سرعت عمل برای من میره بالا. حالا
انتظارمون چیه؟ ببینید وقتی که یه اسپاک
داریم انتظار داریم این یه اصلاح به ما
بده و بره لگ دومشو کامل بکنه که لگ اول
با لگ دوم برابری می‌کنه. این کل مفهوم
این داستانه و از اینجا هم احتمال احتمال
برگشتمون خیلی میره بالا یا اصلاح بعدی و
اعتما لگ بعدی اما تارگت ما اینجاست و اگر
بخواد لگ بعدی وجود داشته باشه ما مجدداً
با این لگ بعدیه ورود می‌کنیم. یعنی نقطه
ورود بعدیمون یه جای دیگهست و به یه سبک
دیگهست. بچه‌ها من به عنوان یه راهنمایی
زیرسیبیلی در مورد لگ سوم این لگ دوم لگ
دومی که می‌زنه و لگ سومی داریم بچه‌هایی
که می‌خواد در مورد این لگ سومه که در
تناسب با این لگ دوم اینا چهجوری اتفاق
میفته بدونن ویدیوی گزارش هفتگی شماره ۱۹
من کامل توضیحش دادم چون الان اینجا بازش
بکنم به قول نقیب بحثو میبریم یه جای دیگه
الان نمیخوام بحثو ببرم یه جای دیگه واسه
همین اینو فعلاً دست نگه دارید در موردش
فعلاً لگ وان لگ تو لگ تریو میخواید از
این برید داستانهای دیگه‌ای داشت که من
اونجا صحبت کردم کامل در موردش ولی الان
بحثو ببریم یه جای دیگه کلاً خراب میشه
ویدیو پس الان انتظار داریم بعد از این
افزایش یه اصلاح داشته باشیم و بریم لگ
بعدی رو هم اندازه این لگ بسازیم همونجوری
که توی اول ویدیو دیدید من اومدم اول به
صورت اجرایی یه ریزشی داشتیم من باین
پولبک اومدم سلم رو گذاشتم و این هرچی رفت
بالاتر من عمله دومم اینجا زدم یعنی دو
ایکسم رو اینجا زدم ۱۲ می بود امروز ۱۳ می
که من دارم این ویدیو رو ضبط می‌کنم یعنی
دیروز بود پس به بیان بهتر وقتی که یک
ترندی برای ما داره تشکیل میشه که لوهای
پایین بالاتر داره می‌زنه یعنی بالا بالا
داره میره لوهامون ال بالاتر ال بالاتر ال
بالاتر ما می‌فهمیم که یک ترند به عنوان
اسپایک ایجاد شده یعنی مرحله اول استراتژی
ما داره انجام میشه و به محض اینکه این
کندل بعدی شروع می‌کنه اصلاح دادن اصلاح
یعنی چی؟ یعنی میاد زیر اولین لو من
می‌تونم اردرم رو اونجا به صورت
دستی یا به صورت
لیمیت از قبل تعیین شده انجام بدم به صورت
لیمیت چه شکلی میشه من وقتی می‌بینم که یک
گپی اینجا انجام شد و یک بریک اوت اینجا
انجام شد و کندل بعدی کندل فارتروش که
اومد نتونست بیاد این شدو پایین‌تری بزنه
و یک فضای ت ارری برای من ایجاد کرد که یه
ترندی ایجاد کرده بایرها وارد شدن
همین جا من می‌فهمم دیگه نیازی نیست منتظر
کندل بعدی بشم یعنی این اصلاً نیاز نیست
منتظر کندل بعدی بشم توی همین سه کندل اول
اردرم رو می‌ذارم و اگه فرض کنیم این سه
کندل تشکیل شده و اصلاً اینا وجود ندارن
تو چارت ما اردر لیمیت من اومده اینجا
گذاشته شده یعنی بای لیمیت
من گذاشته شده حالا این خوبیش اینه که
فاصله شما تا استاپ مشخصه قبل از اینکه
بخواد اردر شما فعال بشه یعنی این فاصله
اس ال شماست حد ضرر شماست چرا که این اگر
برگرده تا اینجا عملاً دیگه این سناریوئه
کلاً ملقاست و این سناریو اصلاً قابل
استناد نیستش و از طرف اگر کندل بعدی هم
اومد تشکیل شد بعد از این من می‌تونم خیلی
راحت اینو پاک کنم الان و اردر بعدیم رو
یعنی اردر اینو دیلیت
کنم و یه اردر جدید متناسب با فاصله هم تا
حد ضرر بذارم اما من این کارو نمی‌کنم من
همینو می‌گیرم می‌کشم میارم م بالا چون
این فاصلهه اونقدر زیاد نیست اگر زیاد
باشه اردر جدید می‌ذارم با یه حجم جدید
اما این فاصله اونقدر زیاد نیست که عموماً
مدیریت سرمایه و مانی منجمنت منو خراب کنه
حالا اولویت اول این استراتژی دقیقاً
همینه که شما مانی منجمنت خوبی
داری مانی منجمنت خوبی داری و از طرفی
ترند از یور فرند یعنی شما در جهت ترند
داری معامله می‌کنی ترند روند روند دوست
شماست و داری داری می‌بینی که داری یه
ترندی تشکیل میشه. سومین حالتش اینه که
شما داری در سیگنال داری ببین یه سیگنال
ورود داری با یک تأییدیه به به قول من
حالا سیگنال نمیشه گفت تأییدیهست شما یک
تأییدیه دیدی از ورود کردن و منظر بعدیش
اینه یعنی گزینه بعدیش اینه علاوه بر
اینکه سیگنال تأییدی روندو دیدی تو دل خود
این هم یه سیگنال بار دیدی هم یه کیبار
دیدی حالا اگه اینا نمی‌دونید چیه باید
دوباره مطالب رو حرفه‌ای‌تر دنبال کنید
نمی‌تونم من همه رو دوباره بک بزنم مطالبو
از اول بگم ولی بدونید که خیلی چیز خوبیه
چون من دارم باهاش کار می‌کنم سال‌هاست و
مشکلی با این باهاش نداشتم به صورت خیلی
جدی فقط یه سری اپتیمایزهای خیلی ساده
می‌خواد و به محض اینکه بچه‌ها این کندل
بعدی شروع می‌کنه اردر شما رو فعال کردن
شما اینجا دقیقاً یک بای
داری و با یک اس ال اینجا حالا اینجا
همونجوری که دیروز دیدید من روز ۱۲ می
اومدم توی دو ایکس این هم وارد معامله شدم
این یک انتخابه که من می‌تونم توی دو ایکس
این هم وارد معامله بشم چرا که بچه‌ها این
یک بحث مدیریت سرمایه‌ایه من اگر از اینجا
تا
اینجا یک ریوارد به دست بیارم معامله دو
ایکس من که از
اینجا تا اینجا انجام میشه ۳ ایکس به در
به دست میاره یعنی مجموعاً من با د تا هم
ریسک کردم دیگه اگه بگیم آقا حتی اگه حجم
این معامله دوم با این برابر باشه یعنی
اگه اینجا مثلاً ۱۰۰ دلار ریز کردم تو
معامله اول تو معامله دومم ۱۰۰ دلار ریز
کرده باشم از این فاصله این اگر بره سود
بده معامله اول ۱۰۰ دلار به دست آوردم اما
معامله دوم من ۳۰۰ دلار به من می‌رسونه پس
در مجموع من عملاً ۴۰۰ دلار سود کردم اگر
این د تا سود بکنن و من ۲۰۰ دلار ضرر کردم
من اینو توی
هایلایت می‌تونید برید مشاهدهش بکنید کامل
این نحوه مدیریت سرمایه رم توضیح دادم که
چهجوری باید انجامش بدید و تیک پرافیت‌های
ما می‌تونن توی تیپی یک باشن و تیپی د
باشن عموماً من خودم بچه‌ها دارم تیپی یک
کار می‌کنم چون با معامله دوم سودم رو
خیلی بزرگ کردم و تیپی د یه مقدار زیاده
واسه این استراتژی چون اونقدر استاپ
کوچیکی ندارید استاپتون نسبتاً بزرگه پس
باید تیپیتونم چیز باشه اما احتمال وقوع
خوبی داره بک تستش باید بکنید بچه‌ها
اصلاً به حرف اینکه آقا محمدعلی پورسمدی
این حرفو زده اعتماد نکنید هر کسی ایک
اومد به شما آموزش داد شما ملزمید برید بک
تستش بکنید به هیچ عنوان روی حرف دیگران
نباید بپرید تو چارت باید برید بک تستش
کنید حداقل برای ۱۰۰ معامله ۵۰ معامله کف
کف که ببینید آقا من کجا اونجا وارد بشم
خوبه حالا به طور کلی سؤال پیش میاد آیا
من هر جای مارکت هر جای مارکت بیام اینو
انجام بدم اوکیه؟ نه من میگم اوکی نیست و
باید برید روی لول‌های مختلف حالا مثلاً
می‌تونید برید دوباره تو هایلایت‌های من
کامل بهتون یاد دادم مثلاً روند
لول‌ها یکی از سطوح خیلی خوبن که می‌تونن
وقتی که قیمت از یک رون لول مثلاً روی طلا
روی مثلاً چه
می‌دونم مثلاً انقدر که زود طلا رسید به
۳۰۰ و چیز من اصلاً عادت دارم بگم طلای
مثلاً ۲۵۰۰ دیگه تهش دیگه به ۳۲۰۰ عادت
ندارم بگم طلای ۳۲۰ دلاریه مثلاً رو ۳۲۰۰
یا مثلاً
۳۲۵۰ یا مثلاً
۳۲۵ اینا عددای رندت الان یا حتی اگه
بخواید خیلی فوق اسکلپی کار بکنید مثلاً
۳۲۵۷ و نیم چون ما اعداد رند رو بر اساس
هر ۲۵۰ پوینت جدا می‌کنیم اینم یک نکته
آموزشی فرا این ویدیو اعداد رندرو هر ۲۵۰
پوینت می‌تونیم جدا کنیم یا اگر براتون
خیلی فاصله کمی داره هر ۵۰۰ پوینت
می‌تونید اینو جدا بکنید یا بازم اگر خیلی
سختتونه و می‌خواید سوینگ بگیرید می‌تونید
هر ۱۰۰۰ پوینت جدا بکنید. این برای فست
اسکلپراست. فست اسکلپرها این برای
اسکلپرهاست. حالا رو داجونزم دقیقاً به
همین چیزه دیگه. شما می‌تونید ۲۵۰ پوینت
کنید داجونز چون می‌دونم به طبق نظرسنجی
که قبلاً گذاشته بودم تقریباً بیش از نیمی
یعنی ۸۰ ۹۰ از بچه‌ها ۹۰ این بچه‌ها که
دارن این ویدیو رو می‌بینن روی طلا و
داجنس کار می‌کنن. چرا؟ چون بچه‌های
حرفه‌ای هستن زرنگن می‌دونن که باید برن
تو جایی کار کنن که حجم معاملاتی بالایی
داره چون این حجم معاملاتی بالا ما رو
نجات میده از اینکه یه نفری وارد بشه تو
مارکت بخواد سیستم کاری ما رو خراب بکنه و
برای جمع‌بندی نهایی وقتی که می‌بینیم این
قیمت بعد از یک رنج حالا این رنج در سطح
کندلی یادتون باشه می‌تونست کوچیک باشه و
در سطح یک رنج طولانی مدتم می‌تونه معیار
ما باشه وقتی که قیمت به یک سمتی جهت پیدا
می‌کنه. ما سعی می‌کنیم با اون جهت برای
گرفتن لگ دوم وارد بشیم. چرا که مزایای
بسیاری داره این لگ دوم باعث میشه که
سیگنال اولو ما دیدیم و بر اساس اون وارد
میشیم و نقطه ورود ما نقطه‌ایه که فوق
بهینه است. یعنی شما سال‌ها باید دست و پا
بزنی تو مارکت که به این نتیجه برسی. جدی
دارم میگم واقعاً هیچ منتی هم نیست که این
نقطه نقطه بسیار بهینه‌ایه اگه برید بکلیس
بگیرید خودتون می‌بینید که حالا دیروز
معامله اذیت کرد یه مقدار تا اینجاها
برگشت و خود این هم داستانهایی داره که من
تو ویدیوهای بعدی بهتون میگم که چهجوری
می‌تونید این اولی رو وارد نشید و بعدش
فقط دو دومی رو وارد بشید فعلاً داریم گرم
می‌کنه یعنی دارم گرمتون می‌کنم ولی با
همین گرم کردنه شما خودتونو بستید چون من
دارم با همین کار می‌کنم سال‌هاست دارم
دلاله کارو می‌گیرم اصلاً بچه‌های
قدیمی‌تر می‌دونن که من همیشه گفتم من یه
اسپایک تریدرم یک پرایس اکشن تریدرم که در
دل پراکس اکشن اسپایک تریدرم اسپایکو
چهجوری ترید می‌کنن؟ یکی از روش کسبکو
می‌کنم همین شکلیه و احتمالاً اگر برید
چارت رو نگاه کنید خیلی موقعیت‌های این
شکلی خواهید دید که موقعیت‌های سکندری
حتی که با برگشتن به این لو کندل بعدی که
کندل بعدی میاد تو دل این و از همین اولین
پولبک برمی‌گرده به سمت بالا برای رسیدن
به لگ
د راحت کارمونو با خ راحت انجام بدیم و
بهترین فرصت‌ها رو زمانی می‌سازه که به یک
سطح مهم می‌رسه. سطح‌های مهممونم تو ویدیو
شماره ۱۹ گفتم که کدوم سط‌های مهم هستن و
خیلی مطلب باز میشه اما اگر باز هم ن
نمی‌دونید سطح مهم چیه هایلایت‌های پیجو
ببینید به نظرم متوجه میشید که باید رو چه
سطحهایی معامله بکنید یا کانتکست محور
معامله کنید بر اساس چرخه‌ها معامله کنید
یعنی ببینید وقتی که یک رنج پرایس اکشنی
داره ایجاد میشه بعد از شکستن این پرایس
اکشنی یعنی رنج پرایس اکشنی می‌تونید مثل
همین معامله امروز بیاید روی این نقطه سل
خوبی داشته باشید حالا برگردیم به معامله
من که دیروز انجام دادم اما قبل اینکه
برگردیم رو چارت بیاد من یه مقدار براتون
باز بکنم که کجاها بهتره که از این سیستم
استفاده بکنیم اولین چیزی که ازتون
می‌خوام دقت کنید تو کل این مجموعه
ویدیوهایی که قراره یک و ۲ تا ۱۲ داشته
باشیم احتمالاً و شایدم داشته باشیم شاید
نداشته باشیم عمر ما کفاف بده نده
نمی‌دونم اما من دارم تلاشم می‌کنم که
این‌دار باشه اما چیزی که ازتون می‌خوام
شما یه کانسپتی دارید اینجا دیگه و
احتمالاً داشتید باهاش کارم می‌کردید تا
الان یعنی مثلاً یه استراتژی هر چقدرم
ساده اصلاً کاری ندار نداریم استجون چی
بوده. اگه داشتید با موینگ اورجا کار
می‌کردید با همون کارتونو ادامه بدید. اما
این صحبتی که من امروز کردمو به عنوان یک
تریگر این رو اضافه کنید بهش. یا مثلاً
اگه بر اساس چرخه‌ها داشتید کار می‌کردید،
بر اساس کانال کار می‌کردید یعنی میومدید
مثلاً می‌گفتید من کف کانال‌ها وارد میشم.
حالا اگر به کف کانال رسیدید دیگه صرفاً
با یک سیگنال وال کیبار وارد نشید. سعی
کنید این روند وان الگ الکتور رو ببینید.
ببینید این شکلی یه کانالی داشتید و این
داره کف کانال می‌رسه یکی از جاهایی که
میشه استفادهش همینجا توی این کف کانال به
جای اینکه سریع بپرید تو سعی کنید ببینید
آیا اینجا داره یک کندلی تشکیل میشه که یک
بریک اوت توش داره و یک فالو تروی خوب
داره و یه گپ اینجا داره و این تشکیل یک
اسپایک داده حالا می‌تونید بیاید منتظر
بشید اینجا یک چیز بذارید اردر بذارید و
باهاش وارد بشید برای سقف کانال من الان
میرم روی چارت دوباره یه ذره مثال براتون
می‌زنم چون یه مقدار بیشتر مثال بزنم
بیشتر ذهنتون عادت می‌کنه به این سیستم
اینو مثال بزنم بعد بریم یعنی بیشتر
می‌خواستم اینجا تمومش کنم اما گفتم بیشتر
مثال بزنم براتون که کامل تو ذهنتون جا
بیفته بچه‌ها برای مثال همین چارت امروزو
تایم فریم ۱ دقیقه طلا هسته من چند تا
مثال براتون اینجا آماده کردم ببینید از
تایم صبحه ببینید اونجا که کار نمی‌کنید پ
صبح حالا اگه کارم نکردید بازم این لگرو
تا اون بالا رفته ببینید این مثالیه که من
زوم حالا با چیز می‌کنم با نرمزار زوم
می‌کنم روشین تعداد زیادی لو بالاتر
داشتیم یکی ۲ تا ۳ تا ۴ تا ۵ تا ۶ تا ۷ تا
۸ تا ۹ تا ۱۰ همه چی زده و اینجا داده
ببین این یه مقدار کارو سخت می‌کنه وقتی
انقدر اسپاکتون بزرگ میشه به عرضش نگاه
کنید وقتی که عرض زیادی می‌زنه ترجیحاً
ورود نکنید البته که این استاپ نزد و رفت
تارگت داد ببینید این استاپش اینجاست و
این استاپ نزد و رفت تارگت یکشو اگر اینو
در نظر بگیریم رفت داد که اینجاها میشه
اما من میگم اینا رو فعلاً کار نمی‌کنیم
خیلی موقعیتهای بدیهی‌تر وقتی مارکت داره
با موقعیتهای خیلی خوب و بدیهی میده چرا
خودمونو اذیت کنیم تو چار اینجا ت ببینید
از ۷ صبح که می‌خوایم شروع به کار کنیم
تایم بروکر میشه مثلاً
۸ ۸ ۹ ایران خب حالا بر اساس اینکه تایم
تابستونی باشه زمستونی باشه داریم کار
می‌کنیم ببینید اومدیم از دقیقاً از
مووینگج ۶۰ تو تایم فریم یک دقیقه‌ای که
میشه همون ۶۰ دقیقه قبل اومدیم یه دونه کف
بالاتر ببینید کف بالا کف بالا کف بالا کف
بالا رفته همینجوری زده و یه عرض خوبی
داره این عرض خوب منم می‌کنه که هم اومده
سقف قبلی رو شکونده می‌تونیم یه تریگر
خیلی خوب روی این نقطه بگیریم که ما اینجا
اگه می‌گرفتیم آره یکشو خیلی بدیهی می‌داد
و ببینید وقتی که موقعیتی خوب رو به موقع
و سریع می‌گیرید. یعنی اون موقعیتی که اول
ترنده عملاً دارید پی گپ می می‌گیرید نه
ای گگپ این ای گگپه فرق پی گپ و ای گپو من
کامل گفتم بهتون تارگتتو خیلی سریع هم بهت
میده یعنی اصلاً نمی‌ذاره خشک بشه تارگت د
هم که تو جیباته حالا ما بازم زیاده روی
نمی‌کنیم برای تارگتهای بالاتر و اینا که
اصلاً وارد فیلم تخیلی میشیم اما میایم
اینجا دوباره یه الگوی خوب می‌بینیم این
الگو اومده شکسته شده پس هم سقفمو شکونده
هم یه ترند خوب برای من ساخته و اونقدر هم
نمی‌تونم بگم رفته به اگزاشن گپ داره
می‌رسه چون اگر این لگ یک ما باشه لگ دو
ما این شکلی ممکنه بشه و کل این میشه لگ
دو این و اینجا می‌تونیم براش ورود کنیم و
تارگتشم یک ببینید همین یک می‌تونید
بگیرید من میگم یک برای اینکه احتمال وقوع
بالایی داره و سخت نکنیم کار خودمونو اما
ببینید وقتی یکی می‌زنه د تا می‌زنه سومی
رو می‌زنه روی این سبخ احتمال خیلی بالایی
داره که این ایگب باشه پس دیگه روی این
ورود نمی‌کنیم این ریسکیه این موقعیت
ریسکیه باید صبر کنیم مارکت بابا خب
فراوونه تایم فریم ۱ دقیقهست همه اونجوری
که الان دیدید دارید انجام میدم از ساعت ۷
صبحه تا ۸ و ۱۵ دقیقه یعنی تو یک ساعت کل
این اتفاقا افتاده و همین اتفاقهم همین
جاها افتاده پس اصلاً عجله‌ای نداریم
منتظر میشیم به یک قیمت تعادلی برسه قیمت
تعادلی میشه مووینگ اوریج تو بازارهای
مالی به قیمت تعادلی میگیم مووینگ اورج
یعنی مووینگ اورجو میگیم قیمت تعادلی و
صبر می‌کنیم قیمت قشنگ بهش برسه اونجا
تصمیمات خودمونو بگیریم یه نکته خیلی فنی
و قشنگ اینجا وجود داره بچه‌ها آقا تو در
مورد این معامله که استاپ خورده من
نمی‌خوام بگم استاپ نباید بخوریم استاپ
می‌خوریم و اینم مثلاً آقا در نظر
می‌گیریم استاپ اما ما یاد گرفتیم وقتی
بازارای مالی دارن باز میشن باز بازار
اروپایی از ۹ و ۱۰ صبح به وقت چیز باز
میشن ۹ و ۱۰ و ۱۱ فرانکفورت و لندن و همه
بانکهاشون و اینا باز میشن می‌دونیم که
اون سناریویی که ساعت ۸ و۴۹ دقیقه ۸ و۵۰
دقیقه وجود داره برا ما اومده سقف بالاتر
زده و کفای بالاتر زده اینجا و تریگر ورود
منو اینجا میده احتمالاً رأس ساعت ۹ فیلد
بشه. اینجا ببینید ۹ رأس ۹ و ۱ دقیقه کلاً
مارکت با یک گپ برگشته و اونچه که برای من
موقعیت معاملاتیست دقیقاً این میت ساعت ۹ه
که اینجا اصلاً بحث استراتژی زمانی میاد
که من در ادامه قراره بازش کنم تو
ویدیوهای بعدی تایم آنالیز میاد که وسط که
اصلاً خود این یک استراتژی زمانیه قبلاً
یادش دادم چه تو تایم نیویورک چه تو تایم
لندن اما بازم روش کار می‌کنیم و اصلاً
می‌تونید خیلی تفکیک شده بر اساس زمان
ببینید خیلی دارم بهتون تیپس خفنی میگما
ما بر اساس این زمانه میاید اول روزای
بازارهای مختلفو می‌تونید با گپ کار کنید
بچه‌ها رفت تموم شد تهشه ته کاره به کی
قسم من دارم اینجوری کار می‌کنم هر روز
برید ببینید اصلاً من نمیگم حرف منو باور
کنید برید رو چارت ببینید بعد برید در
آینده کار کنید نپرید تو چارتا به حرف منو
لطفاً برید ببینید چه اتفاقی داره میفته
رو چارت و اون موقعست که معجزه رو
می‌بینید هر سب اصلاً آقا الان دارید
ویدیو رو می‌بینید سبک سبکت یه چیز دیگهست
اصلاً داری با یه سبک روش دیگه‌ای کار
می‌کنی اما بیا این تریگررو بنداز توش.
معجزه رو اون موقع می‌بینی که این سیستم
تریگر گرفتن با اسپایک‌ها بسیار به شما
سیگنالهای خوبی میده. یک یه کندل ۲ کندل ۳
کندل ساختیم و اینجا ما می‌تونیم تریگر
ورود سلیتمونو بذاریم اینجا در عرض ی و د
و ۳ دقیقه کلاً وقت ما رو گرفته تا تریگر
بده و تریگر دوشم داده یعنی تیپی دوشم
داده حالا اینجا ما هر آنچه که یاد گرفتیم
اون که نمی‌خوایم فراموش کنیم ما یاد
گرفتیم که مارکت یه سری چرخه‌ها داره
مارکت یه سری پولبک‌های بزرگ در تارفرم
بالاتر داره که این داره عملاً میاد به
اول لگ دوش ببینید گفتم اگر اینو لگ یک
بگیریم اینو کلاً لگ د این داره برمی‌گرده
دقیقاً به پولبک به اینجا اینجا می‌زنه ما
ما این دید بازمون رو حفظ می‌کنیم و
اونجاست که میاد دوباره لو بالا لو بالا
لو بالا لو بالا لو بالا می‌زنه درسته که
این عریض شده ولی تو دل اینه می‌تونیم با
یک موقعیتی که حالا این احتمالش کمتره
بچه‌ها تو بحث مانی منجمنت وقتی احتمال
سیستمت اینجوری میاد پایین‌تر به جای
اینکه نکته خیلی قشنگیه‌ها به جای اینکه
نگیریش به جای اینکه حالا ۲ ریسک بکنی روش
میای ۱ ریسک می‌کنی روش به جای اینکه اگه
۱ ریسک می‌کردی
نیم ریسک می‌کنی روش اما تریگرتو می‌گیری
وقتی داره در جهتت معامله می‌کنه و میاد
یه تیپی خیلی خوشگل از دو ایکس بهت میده
یعنی شما اگه اینجا ورود بایتو می‌زدی بای
لیمیت می‌ذاشتی اینجا بهت موقعیت مجدد
داده بود من اینو تمیزش کنم خیلی شروغ شد
و این ببینید تو مارکتهای رنج اگر
می‌خواید کار بکنید دیگه باید برید تو دل
اینا کار بکنید که من توصیه نمی‌کنم سعی
کنید وقتی مارکت ترتمیزه کار بکنید و بعدش
خیلی سادهست وقتی می‌بینید که مارکت داره
اینجوری کثیف میشه ببینید کندلا رو
می‌بینید چقدر کثیفن اصلاً مشخص مشخص
می‌کنه مارکت می‌خواد ادا دربیاره واقعاً
داد می‌زنه. اینا کن اصلاً مشخص آقا من
نمی‌خوام به تو سود بدم می‌بینید اینا رو
چقدر زشتن اصلاً مقایسهش بکنید با اینجا
بریم عقب‌تر با اینجا اینجا چقدر شکیله
اینجا چقدر کثیفه اما تو دل این ما بازم
پوزیشن داریم ببینید یه جایی که ترتمیز
میشه لو پایین لو پایین لو پایین این توو
داده اس ال اینجا این توری اینجا لگ دوش ۱
د و خیلی تمیز کارشو برات انجام میده بعد
که مجدد میایم به تا ساعت‌های خوب می‌رسیم
برای امروز ببینید اون صبح بود اینجا صبح
بود و وقتی به ساعتهای خوشگل دوباره
می‌رسیم که ساعت‌های نیویورکه انقدر دیگه
اینجا موقعیت هست دیگه می‌سپارم به تمرین
خودتون که ببینید الان اینجا موقعیتها رو
برای من پیدا بکنید که چقدر قشنگ اومده
موقعیت‌هایی داده لو پایین این اردرت
اس این یکش دوش و الی ماشااللهش دوباره
برمی‌گرده به سطح تعادل و اینجا کندلا
کثیف میشن مجدد بچه‌ها اصلاً مارکت وقتی
می‌خواد کثافتکاری دربیاره داد می‌زنه
ببخشید من کلمه استفاده می‌کنم ولی واقعاً
برازنده این قسمت از چارت برای بچه‌هایی
که ریل کار می‌کنن می‌دونن چیزی جز این
کلمه که من گفتم نیست اما تو دل همین میشه
اردرهای خوبی
گرفت برای آ اردر یک اما بازم میگم این
برا فوق پروفشناله از شما انتظار دارم که
مارکت وقتی داره تمیز کار می‌کنه کار کنید
باهاش تمیز چیه تمیز اینجا اینجاست که
وقتی میاد از این محدوده‌ای که خودش برات
ساخته این شکلی می‌شکنه ۱ ۲ ۳ لو پایین‌تر
اینجا شما سل باید
می‌ذاشتی آره یکتو نسبت به این عرض خیلی
تمیز میده بچه‌ها این چیزی که من به شما
یاد دادم اسمش معجزه است معجزه‌ای که شما
تا وقتی رو چارت نبینیش باورش نمی‌کنی
دوباره تو برگشت ببینید ما اینجا گپو
داریم پس این داره میره سقفهای بارتر
می‌زنه که کفهای بارتر می‌زنه ۱ ۲ ۳ ۴ ۵ ۶
اینجا می‌بینید از اینجا اردر بعدی لگ
دباره در ادامه از مووینگ اوریج داره حرکت
می‌کنه از مووینگ اوریج از این سطح ۱ ۲ ۳
۴ ۵ اومده حرکت کرده این محدوده رو برای
من ساخته نه تنها تریگر نقطه یکتو داده و
اومده دقیقاً برگ زده و همونجور که خودتون
می‌دونید جایی که قیمت برمی‌گرده جایی که
تیپی درستی بوده این همونو که از ویدیوها
به یادگار مونده از از ما دیگه این دو
ایکسشم داده و عملاً ۴ سود در مقابل ۲
ریسک و مجدد برمی‌گرده بچه‌ها برمی‌گرده
به مووینگ اوریج اینجا دوباره میاد سقف
بالا کف بالا ببخشید کف بالا کف بالا کف
بالا اردر بای لیمیت اینجا فعال شده دیگه
مارکت چهجوری باید برا شماشو نشون بده
چقدر باید خوشگل هم آموزشش بدم هم شما
ببینیدش هم چقدر حال داریم می‌کنیم دور
همدیگه چقدر قشنگه و این چون گذشتهست این
خیلی سادهست یه مووینگ اوریج ۶۰ ای ام ا
شما می‌تونید برید بندازید تو چارتتون در
تایم فریم ام۱ و با این سبک اس پی تو
کارتونو انجام بدید و می‌بینید که
معجزه‌ها آروم آروم رخ میدن روی چارت شما
از اون طرفم وقتی دوباره میاد به این سط
می‌رسه میاد بریک اوتو با گپ مجدد خیلی
قشنگ می‌زنه برات تریگر نزولیته اینجا
استاپته دوباره اینجا احتمالاً دو ایکستو
داده بعد اینجا میاد قبل اینکه دو ایکسو
بده تیپ یکشو داده. بچه‌ها من نمی‌خوام
شما رو دچار دچار یه سوگیری کنما.
سوگیری تأییدی بهش میگن. نمی‌خوام دچار
سوگیری تأییدی بشید که هی دنبال چیزایی
بکردید که حرف شما رو تأیید کنه. دنبال
نقصاشم می‌کردیم، ضرراشم می‌بینیم.
می‌دونیم این سیستم ضررها هم داره اما
می‌دونیم که یه سیستم به شدت قدرتمندی
داره یاد گرفتیم که می‌تونیم در زمان
مناسب، در مکان مناسب خیلی خوب، خوشگل
استفادهش بکنیم. خب بچه‌ها این مدت خیلی
طولانی که الان اینجا وایساده از نظر
زمانی به نظر من دیگه باید وقتشه که بریزه
دیگه اگه نریزه یه ذره نگران کننده میشه
یعنی این داره قدرت این سناریوی ما از بین
میره کمکم و من منتظرم دیگه این لگ‌های
بعدی لگ به سمت تیپی باشه خب بچه‌ها
معاملاتمون رسیده به نقطه‌ای که همشون
تقریباً وارد سود دارن میشن به اون مرز
لبه پایینی رسیده
من حد سود این پایینیه رم فکر کنم باید
بذارم این سه تا معامله پایینی رو دقیقا
میذارم اینجا اینجا اینم کنم ۳۷ حالا و
منتظرم که به اینجا برسه و معامله آخرم رو
الان تیپی براش نذاشتم یعنی این معامله که
آخرین بهترین نقطه ورود من اینجا بوده
دیگه یعنی این پوزیشن آخر رو تیپی براش
نمی‌ذارم الان رو ریوارد دوشم یعنی اون
پوزیشن آخری که زدم آر دوشو گرفتیم این
پوزیشن پایینی رو آر یکشه پوزیشن اولمونم
میانگینش این د تا پوزیشن اول میانگینشون
داره نزدیک به یک میشه یعنی مجموع تراز به
سود سود رفته و مجموعاً ۸۰۰ دلار تو
سودیم. من اینم یهکم زومین‌تر می‌کنم تا
بهتر دیده بشه همه چی.
[موسیقی]
خب بچه‌ها تقریباً به تیپی ما رسیده من رو
عدد ۱۵ گذاشته بودم چیزمو چون عدد ۱۵ عدد
مهمه یعنی از اینجا تا اینجا خودش یه دونه
داستان میتونه باشه اگه با قدرت نریزه من
بذار تایم فریمو ببرم بالاتر بهتر دیده
بشه این ۵ دقیقهشه یا زوم اوت بکنم ببینید
تموم شد این معاملات ما بسته شد و میمونه
اون معامله آخر اون معامله آخر به این
شکله الان ریوارد سه و نیم چ۴ارشه
ان د تا انتخاب داریم اینجا تو این مرحله
من می‌تونم بیام روی این کلیک کنم بیام
نصف پوزیشنمو ببندم یعنی بگم ۲وده دهمشو
از چهاردهم ببند حالا تو اکانت هیستوری من
الان چار تا پوزیشن هست الان یعنی عملاً
۸۰ پوزیشن‌ها بسته شدن حالا می‌تونیم
دوباره
بیایم اینم دوباره یه راه حله از نظر مری
منجمنت دوباره یه نصفشو ببیم ۹۰ش بسته شده
باشه اما یه راه حل هم هست مثل من راه حل
من چیه من معمولاً همه اینا رو کلاً
می‌بندم م چرا چون به نظر من همه جای
مارکت موقعیته من اینو یه بار براتون باز
بکنم این کل پوزیشن‌هاست یعنی حالا چار تا
بود که من پوزیشن آخر به س قسمت تقسیم
کردم که فقط نشون بدم که این روش مانی
منجمنت هم قابل انجامه برای کسایی که
میخواست سود بیشتری بگیرن ۱۵۰۰ دلار
تقریباً میشه د و نیمد فکر کنم دو س۳ سود
کردیم در مقابل نیم تا ۱ فکر کنم ریسک روی
این اکانت و مقدار معقولیه ۱ بخوای بذاری
بری و ۳ بگیری تقریباً حالا چرا این اتفاق
افتاد ببین برای من مطلب اینجا بود
می‌گفتم اگه این لگ اگه قراره برگرده کلاً
سناریوی ریزشی من داره به انتهای خودش
نزدیک میشه یا اصلاً تموم شدهست پس
اینجاست که من می‌تونم بیام روی این
ببینید یه سقفی داشتیم اینجا اومده سقف
پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر عملاً
چار تا سقف پایین‌تر در جهت این روند قبلی
ساخته من دنبال لگ دوم این بودم به طور
کلی ببینید این لگ اولش بوده اگه از اینجا
بگیریم
میشه لگ دومش اینجا این لگو منتظرش بودم
حالا این لگ خودش برای خودش یه تول داشته
تو خودش ببینید این لگ میشه لگ اول عملاً
تو لگشو ساخت تموم شد یعنی عملاً تیپی من
اینجا خورده بود ولی چیکار کردم گفتم میام
لگ دوم اینو می‌گیرم چون سناریوی اصلیم
چیه سناریو اصلیم اینه که این کلاً لگ این
کلاً و از اصلاحش که اصلاحش خیلی عمیق بود
میشه از اینجا
تا اینجا لگ بعدیشه که الان دقیقاً رسیدیم
به رأس لگ بعدیش و توی مسیر هم بچه‌ها
بارها این اتفاق افتاد یعنی بارها این
اتفاق من هی می‌خواستم بگیرم خودمو خیلی
کنترل کردم که این کارو نکنم چون میخواستم
ذهنتون مشوش نشه از اینکه تعداد زیادی از
استراتژیها رو بخوام براتون جلو بذارم
جلوتون ولی ببینید دقیقاً بچه‌ها ببینید
عین همون اتفاق داره میفته یه سقف بالاتر
اینجا داریم بالاترین سقفمونه از بعد از
اینکه نزدیک استاپ من شد دوباره اومدیم
سقفهای پایین‌تر یه اسپ این سمت بالا
دوباره سقفا پایین‌تر یه تا به سمت بالا
اینا همه نقطه ورودای این ریزشه اگه
می‌خواست این به حالت ریز اینجاها دو دل
بوده باشیم میایم صبر می‌کنیم تا جایی که
یک لگ عمیق ببینیم ببینید لگ عمیق من از
کجا شروع شده از اینجا یک یه سقف بالاتر
سقف پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر
سقف پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر سقف پایین‌تر ۱
۲ ۳ ۴ ۵ ۶ ۷ تا سقف پایین‌تر و میام این
اردرم رو می‌ذارم اینجا می‌کشم پایین
می‌کشم پایین می‌کشم پایین می‌کشم پایین
تا اینجا فعال بشه و عملاً لگ اول من که
از اینجا تا اینجا بوده اسپاگ لگ توی من
میش میشه اینجا گرفت شد یعنی تیپی این
پوزیشن اینجا بوده برای ریوارد یک اما
همیشه یادتون باشه که قراره ما کندل به
کندل نگاه کنیم مارکتو حتی اگه تایم
فریممون یک دقیقه‌ایه باید بگیم این کندل
ایجاد شد کندل بعد کندل بعد کندل بعد کندل
بعد مارکت داره کندل به کندل تشکیل میشه
شما نمی‌تونی یه نگاه کلی بهش بکنی بعد
نظر بدی چون تو هر کندل ممکنه سناریو عوض
بشه یعنی تا اینجا یه سناریو بوده از
اینجا به بالا سناریو افزایشی بوده و خود
این یک فصل اسکل که الان اصلاً جاش توی
این ویدیو نیست بخوام در مورد اینا صحبت
بکنم تو ویدیوهای تکمیلی در موردش صحبت
کردم فسی کلپ گرفتن چه‌جوریه چه‌جوری باید
کار بکنیم روش و از همین نقطه ببینید یه
یه مقدار رو همین محدوده بازی کرد و الان
داره یه افزایش تقریباً چند دلاری رو از
کفش ترجمه می‌کنه از ۳۰۸ و نیم تا ۱۵ دلار
رفته بالاتر و این همونجاییه که من میگم
خارج میشم دیگه دنبال این یه ذره نیستم
این پول چایی بچه‌هاست پول شایه بچه‌ها
معروفه دیگه ما اینجا خارج شدیم و این همه
گشت دور خودش آخر سرم نریخت رفت بالاتر و
اینجا ما کل موقعیت داشتیم دیگه
می‌تونستیم موقعیتهای بهتری بگیریم با
استراتژیهای دیگه با استراتژی‌هایی که
حالا من تو ویدیوهای بعدی اشاالله بهش
اشاره می‌کنم که به چه شکل میشه با اینا
خیلی تمیز کار کرد فکر می‌کنم خوشحال
خواهید بود اگه برید اینو بک تست بگیرید و
ببینیدش رو چارت خودتون استفادهش خواهید
کرد اصلاً دیگه چشمتون نمی‌تونه غیر از
این مدلی که من دارم چارتو می‌بینم چار تا
جور دیگه‌ای ببینه و اینم همون حسابه به
عنوان حوصله ختام من بیارمش تایم فریمشو
از همون تاریخی که من پارسال بود ۲۰ ۲۴
بود اف جان که آلمان بودم ببینید این همون
حسابه که الان ۱۰۰ هزار تا واریز کردیم
۱۱۴ ۰۰۰ تا برداشت کردیم اینا هم چیزی
نیست اینا یه سری معاملاته که همسر بنده
انجام دادن توش نکنن کلاً شده اکانت تست
دیگه چون سود خالصه کلاً به عنوان اکانت
تست داره استفاده میشه کوچولو کوچولوها
برای من نیستن معاملاتش برا همسر محترمه
داشت یه سری کارا می‌کرد روی این اکانت خب
بچه‌ها امروز امروزم روز ۱۳ میو من اومدم
یه برداشت داخلی هم زدم ازش به عدد ۱۳ رو
چارت به عنوان یادگاری بمونه سیزدهم من ۱۳
اسفند قول این ویدیو رو دادم ولی ۱۳ می
آمادهش کردم ببخشید می‌دونم دیر کردم ولی
دیگه دارم شروع کردم دیگه قدرتی شروع
کردیم و اینم دقیقاً از جایی که ما خروج
زدیم یاتونه گفتم عدد ۱۵ مهمه عدد ۱۵ میشه
دقیقاً اینجا گفتم از عدد ۱۳ تا ۱۵ عدد
مهمیه چه این گفتنا از رو هوا نیست یعنی
اون گذشته مارکت وقتی زیاد می‌بینی
می‌فهمی که از ۱۵ اینا برمی‌خواد بگرده
چون داریم به یه عدد خیلی بزرگ‌تر نزدیک
میشیم اون عدد بزرگتره ۳۲۰ه این عدد ۳۲۰
رو الزاماً چون از یه عدد بزرگی اومده
یعنی از عدد بالایی شروع کرده بود اومده
بود از
۳۳۲۶ اومده بود من انتظار نداشتم که بیاد
۳۲۰ امروز تاج بکنه و انتظار یه اصلاح
وجود داشت که دقیقاً از همون جا اگه دقت
بکنید بریم تایم فریم یه دقیقه‌ای دوباره
ببینید همین طور رفت بالا از اینجا که ما
خروج کردیم پول چای بچه‌ها رو اگه
نمی‌دادیم و خروج نمی‌کردیم الان قشنگ نه
تنها حد ضررمون می‌خورد بلکه اگه ۱ شیطون
گولمون می‌زد حد ضررمونو می‌بردیم هی
بالاتر هی بالاتر می‌گفتیم پشت این پشت
این پشت این الان این اتفاق میفتاد نگاه
کنید تا این بالا ضرر بوده یعنی به مثلاً
ریسک می‌خواستیم بکنیم دیگه سیونو بیشتر
بکنیم از ۲ می‌بینی ۲۰ ۱۰ ضرر کردیم تا
این لحظه اگر نمی‌بستیم معاملمونو پس به
حد سود و حد ضررتون لطفاً پایبند بمونید
بریم جمع‌بندی نهایی خداحافظی دوستون دارم
ارادت خب بچه‌ها امیدوارم که مطالب مفید
بود باشه توی این ویدیوی اول و بتونید
باهاشون کار کنید، تمرین کنید. چون اینا
همشون تو ویدیوهای بعدی استفاده قراره
بشن. یعنی سلسله. این ویدیو رو باید کار
کنید، متوجه بشید، مستر بشید مخصوصاً رو
اون بحثی که نگاهمون باید کندل به کندل
بریم جلو نه به صورت موج به موج بریم جلو
و سایکل‌ها رو بیایم پیدا بکنیم. تو اون
سایکل‌ها بیایم اون کندل شماریا رو انجام
بدیم. بچه‌ها فوت کوزهگری ته کار همینه.
یعنی تشه و می‌دونم استفاده می‌کنید.
اوکیه. یعنی دلم نمی‌سوزه از اینکه دارم
اینا رو میگم. چون خیلیا گفته بودن که
اینا رو شما داری میگید یه سری میرن الان
دوباره سواستفاده می‌کنن، دورهش می‌کنن،
دوباره دوره می‌فروشن. خب بچه‌ها ببینید
ما نمیتونیم روی مردم کنترلی داشته باشیم
که ما مجبوریم کار درستو انجام بدیم. حالا
یه نفر میخواد سواستفاده کنه من نمیتونم
اینو ندم بهش سواستفاده کنه. ولی دیگه
می‌دونید تو یه وضعیتی هستیم که واقعاً
اگر دیگه آگاه نشده باشی بعد از این همه
داستانایی که پیش اومده توی مارکت حس
می‌کنم دیگه واقعاً حقش اون که اذیت بشه
تو این داستان چقدر دیگه آدم بیاد روشن
گرایی کنه نمیخواد دیگه بسه دیگه کامل
گفته شده مطالب اونی که بخواد استفاده
میکنه اونی که بخواد تو پاچهش بره میره
دیگه من کنترلی روش ندارم من کارمو دارم
می‌کنم با قدرتم می‌کنیم اینم داره دیگه
تایمش تموم میشه بریم ارادت دوستتون دارم
فعلاً
‏Yeah.